[metal detector beeping]
- --isolate that clump.
NARRATOR: In the
northern Philippines,
John Casey and Manny
Paez are inside a cave
searching for what they hope
is Yamashita's treasure.
After running into problems
at their first dig site,
Breach 6--
How the hell would
silt get in here?
NARRATOR: --they turned
to advanced technology
to find another way
into the mountain.
This right here could
be a cave entrance.
NARRATOR: Inside the
cave, they've discovered
a group of coded symbols.
Markers on these rocks.
NARRATOR: And after
triangulating them together,
the team found a rock
marked with a distinct X--
There's a chisel mark
in this thing of an X.
NARRATOR: --which John
believes could be concealing
a small treasure,
a larger chamber,
or possibly even the entrance
to a network of tunnels.
It's a marker telling
us, get the shovel.
We're going to dig right now.
[metal detector beeping]
NARRATOR: Before
breaking ground,
John gives the area one last
sweep with his metal detector.
We got a pretty
decent-size target.
When I cross over
the center, I'm
getting a really decent hit.
It could be a barrel
of anything, you know,
a barrel of coins.
Yeah, this rock could be marking
the entrance to a tunnel,
for all I know.
Hey, Manny?
MANNY: Yeah.
I'm super suspicious that
it's too easy, you know,
that that marker is just way
out right in the blatant open.
That marker over there,
it's just alone by itself.
Why?
Then why does it line
up to that one almost
in a perfect triangle?
There's something very
suspicious about it.
Maybe they're
trying to trick you.
The giveaway marker, the
triangulation and the X marker,
line up way too easy.
There's something about
it that's a little fishy.
It's making me a
little nervous--
hesitant to go forward.
My gut is telling me it's--
there's something wrong here.
Just digging on it
could be disastrous.
So don't put a shovel
in the ground just yet.
We've just got to
be smarter than them
and figure it out safely.
MANNY: All right.
In all my years
of treasure hunting,
I've never seen
X marks the spot.
We have to look around a
little further because there's
just something not right.
I'm getting a bad feeling.
Oh.
That's a flower.
In the Yamashita
codes, that means bomb.
[explosion]
That's no good.
I'm not going to
take any chances
in triggering that bomb.
NARRATOR: In order to
investigate the cave safely,
the team has invited
an explosive ordinance
and military expert
to the mountain.
Somebody call for a bomb guy?
Chad Higginbotham.
Pete Struzzieri.
Good to meet you.
John Casey.
Good to meet you, John.
NARRATOR: John and Manny lead
Chad to the top of the mountain
so they can get
his expert opinion
about what they're possibly
dealing with inside the cave.
JOHN: I've been dying to
get back into this cave
and keep exploring, but
it's been too dangerous.
So now that Chad's here,
we can get back in there
and safely explore
what may have been one
of Yamashita's headquarters.
Let me take a look
around for a minute.
Y'all just kind of
hang out right here.
JOHN: Sure thing.
[music playing]
NARRATOR: General
Yamashita is reported
to have placed booby
traps within all Golden
Lily treasure sites.
Using his years of ordnance
disposal experience,
Chad explores the cave
interior for signs
of old World War II explosives.
All right, I don't
see anything obvious.
NARRATOR: With Chad's approval,
John and Manny start digging
around the X-marked rock.
Whoop.
Oh, hold on, boys.
Hold on a second.
What do you got?
Oh.
Look at that.
[laughs]
We found a coin, boys.
Look at that.
That's definitely a coin.
That's not garbage.
Yep, it is.
You want to clean it up?
Yeah, we got some water?
Oh.
Can I see it?
It's the first piece of
treasure we found on this site.
Oh, I'm so excited.
Where there's one,
there's two, baby.
Oh, that's freakin' killer.
Let's see it a little closer.
CHAD: Finding something
like that in here,
it's a pretty good sign for you.
No doubt.
Finding this coin is great.
But what the hell is it doing
5,000 feet up a mountain
buried next to a
rock with an X on it?
Oh, Manny.
We have to share it with Pete.
He's going to be stoked.
Put it somewhere safe now.
MANNY: It's a good site, John.
It's a beautiful day.
[music playing]